welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how to beat
those charges in court get your case
thrown out on a technicality everybody
run free don't let the man keep you down
we all know you didn't do it my name is
mt and i'm here today with off-screen
producer brandon what's going on brother
that's right mt don't let the man keep
you down don't ever talk to the cops
keep the house shut get your lawyer in
there seriously what are you doing
seriously it's it's good advice if cops
ever make you feel like you have to talk
to them you never have to talk to the
cops
you want to talk you want to talk to
your lawyer instead get daredevil in
here you talk to daredevil you don't
talk to me but what's our big question
for today brandon well empty with the
premiere of she-hulk on disney plus just
around the corner we're about to get a
look at a more judicial side of the mcu
we've seen a lot of the order now it's
time to see the law baby once the flashy
battles have concluded and all the
flying around and the pew projectiles
how do you bring some actual justice to
the villains of the mcu and with the
myriad of offenses racked up against
them who in the eyes of the law is the
actual biggest baddie out there it all
leads us to this week's big question
who would be the biggest criminal for
the department of justice to prosecute
in she-hulk well let's throw a book at
all of these criminals brother because
we're going to take a look at some of
the biggest offenders of the mcu and see
if we can figure out who would have
racked up the most charges and we'll try
and focus on those criminals that are
still alive or at least you know
potentially still alive and additionally
we might have to rule out any you know
aliens gods extra dimensional beings
mainly because they may not be subject
to u.s laws
because they live very far away and uh
don't care
that's true are you gonna like lock up
door mamamoo he doesn't even have hands
how are you gonna handcuff him what are
you gonna do it reminds me one time uh
oh it's really sketchy uh part of
she-hulk's history where eros was on
trial
and he was like you know what things
aren't going my way i'm going to fly
away
you don't have to like stop him from
flying away very messy part of marvel
history good luck trying to put a gun on
trial
and you might be thinking to yourself
that's crazy lock those aliens up well
you know that's easier said than done
plus look at one of the doj's most
winnable cases loki because loki invaded
new york city with an alien army he
caused millions of dollars in damage and
according to some facts thrown out in
civil war
74 people were killed which i personally
believe is absolutely god
that is it's gotta be so much
no way like way more than like that's
like hundreds hundreds easily
thunderbolt ross said that in civil war
and i was like get out of here you're
out of your mind 74
74 bro they had a freaking space whale
knocking over buildings bro like no no
way no way jose that was like a personal
uh punch by kevin feige to warner
brothers being like you killed so many
people and superman man of steel
batman versus superman
mcu alien protecting new york 74 people
died that's it that's it only 74 there's
only like six people fighting these
aliens 74 people only 74 people died get
it get out of here but did they put loki
on trial no they just extradited him
back to asgard where's the justice there
like i think that that sets a precedent
that we can use for today because aliens
and guards aren't really being put on
trial i mean that is when you really
think about it the end of adventures
when they're like you know they're at
the park and loki and thor are like okay
bye and it's like you let this guy go
you let him go the people in new york
should be in the streets like hey will
you let loki go
what's going on what the [ __ ]
yeah the people in new york want blood
like easily like
yeah they don't they don't forget they
want loki's they saw a beat up
spider-man and they were ready to tear
duck apart with their
hands
you want to get to him you got to go
through me yo you ain't getting this boy
on our train you're telling me loki just
walks away from the crime like that's
that's some bs that's some bs that's
whack yeah that's whack but hey what are
you going to tell thor what to do not me
not me
i guess not so with all that in mind
let's begin by going through our
candidates for the biggest legal
criminal in the mcu and we'll start off
with a big screen defendant who we are
going to be seeing on she-hulk
abomination and let's list some of the
abominations crimes here because at
first there's obviously property damage
throughout all of harlem we also have
the assault on bruce banner as well as
random civilians you know throughout his
tenure of uh being the abomination a lot
of civilians got hurt he's beating up
people yeah he's beating up people he
can't allow it the manslaughter of
citizens police and soldiers there was a
cover story on the new york bulletin
that said that there were several dozen
citizens police officers and military
personnel were killed so we have like
the new york bulletin which also it
shows up in the movies they've been
reading it and stuff but it also shows
up on like this you know the netflix
shows and this is pre disney getting
those rights back but ben in his office
you can see a bunch of articles i think
an article there's there's an article
cover you can see of like the duel of
harlem or the battle of harlem whatever
they call it and there's a little thing
at the bottom where it says like several
dozen citizens so multiple factors of 12
number of citizens
police officers and military personnel
were killed almost 76 almost 76. we have
to also look at there's a similar cover
that was done for like the battle of new
york that had said like hundreds dead or
something like that now these were on
the tv shows so we don't know how much
they translate over
you know is this like a different
timeline where there also was a battle
in new york and there also was a duel of
harlem
where the death counts are higher i
don't know i don't know newspapers
exaggerate maybe i don't i don't know
what the answer is here
at least go back and watch the
incredible hulk one person had to die at
least we'll say at least one person is
dead yeah but he's definitely killing
like police and military personnel i
don't know about civilians but like he's
definitely murdered people so he's got
we'll say it's manslaughter right
because it's not premeditated he wasn't
like i'm gonna turn into the abomination
and kill this guy he just turned into
the abomination and he killed some
people now you might you could he could
plead insanity but i don't know i don't
know we'll see we'll see what else what
other crimes does this man have well i
guess technically we could also say
stealing government property because the
hulk's blood at least in you know
ross's eyes yes government property ah
that's a good point that's a good point
because banner turns into hulk while
he's working for ross right and he's
hired by the government and so he
probably had to sign a contract that was
like any intellectual property i come up
with while i'm working for you you guys
own so in theory they own his blood
uh yeah i like that i like that
technically yeah i mean yeah technically
he is property of the us government much
like uh they sort of viewed um what's
his johnny mayonnaise as a property of
the us government in a way and so and a
vision vision was property of the us
government as well even though i think
that's questionable i think that's
questionable he's really the property of
helen dr cho he's dr cho's property in
my mind this is true she made vision in
her own she's the only human there that
was not a that was not a us government
facility that was her personal lab maybe
she was being funded by the korean
government i don't know
but vision belongs to helen cho give
them back give them back seriously they
should be married instead yes dan halen
and vision
i hope white vision goes to find helen
show and he's like take me back that is
so true like people don't really like
i've never considered helen cho as like
a person that white vision would go to
but like she is one she's the creator
she's the creator but also false
imprisonment of samuel stearns and
making him inject blonsky with you know
more of that hulk blood because like he
sort of held samuel stearns against his
will he's like hey give me some of that
blood i want to be crazy
and you say i was like sure i'm also
crazy
i am also a crazy we're both health
villains you don't you can put that gun
down i will give this to you for free
yeah yeah he did force him to inject him
okay okay okay yeah i take that now you
say he wants to go crazy
this is the thing do we think
that a meal on she-hulk is gonna like
plead insanity for any of this because
he was kind of tricked into it i think
so like thunderbolt ross is like oh i
need you to do this thing for me i'm
going to give you a little goof juice
it's going to make you happy they didn't
really tell them
what he was facing right he's like i'm
going to make you a little bit stronger
because the guy you're after he's a
little tough and emil blonsky was like i
can bait him i don't need it and then he
got his back broken no i think that
abomination is is sort of going with
this like weird
trying to trick the public into like i
was crazy in the past but like now i'm
cool because like it seems like from
these uh she-hulk promo material that
like he's started a cult he started this
weird like a ball mustang
which is like a play on namaste obama's
day cult and he has like flower girl
like girls with flower reeds watching
him and it's just like he's i think he's
making a case for himself he's like you
know i'm cool now like you can let me go
like i'm totally fine but we all know
he's not fine he needs to stay behind
boss let's talk about aldrich killian
because he went boom thanks to pepper
potts and iron man 3 but who knows how
extreme this extremist stuff really is
like maybe he's not dead forever like
maybe he could have somehow reformed i
think that's 100 within the realms of
possibilities this little brain stem is
still there maybe it can still grow a
whole bunch exactly i don't know the
whole theme of that movie was
regenerating limbs and regenerating your
body so if anyone is going to survive
being blasted it's it's all versus
killian but for the sake of this big
question today even though it may or may
not be possible let's just say he
survived so like what charges could the
doj bring up against mr killian okay so
first of all we got fraud easily because
like he deceived the government to
receive funding for a disabled veterans
program he wasn't telling them what's up
yeah like and he was likely deceiving
private investors as well so that's kind
of messed up we also can add negligence
tied to product liability because
essentially knowing that extremists is
blowing people up not the best thing
ever like he knew the risk he's like 50
50. yeah who knows yeah yeah
i know it's blowing people up but i
gotta keep trying
right i mean like nothing venture
nothing
you can't make an omelette without
cracking a few eggs and we know that
that one guy blew up a bunch of people
in a bar like those people should all
still be alive because he knew that his
product was faulty but he was still
trying it on people also assaults on
many people including a waiter at a
hotel
and pepper potts and tony stark he he
did a lot of assaulting them yeah
he did not care about the law he had a
glowy fire breath he was ready to use it
i mean i don't blame him yes destruction
of property big time big time you
definitely use that breath on a lot of
property and all those veterans uh
helped him with in his plans um but they
were evil veterans but not the good
veterans that we love and uh
some of them just wanted some help some
of them chose the side of violence but
some of them wanted some help i wish we
saw more of their side in the movie it's
like yeah we're just like the minions
but like they were just looking for
a like a better pat like a better future
they wanted their arm back they wanted
their leg back
that's all we see that some of them are
still alive in chiang chi they're
fighting uh in a tournament oh it's just
point five point but also we could also
talk about domestic terrorism because uh
yeah uh basically funding everything
that uh trevor slattery the mandarin was
doing as you know the fake mandarin yeah
um so yeah that was uh that's a pretty
big pretty big crime that's a big
problem
false imprisonment and kidnapping of
pepper potts james rhodes and tony stark
of course among others uh god knows how
many people he's kidnapped probably
kidnapped a lot of people he had a whole
compound full of potentially kidnapped
people terrible person and also
attempting to kidnap president ellis in
crashing a plane putting several people
at risk i mean he did kidnap president
ellis basically yeah
he got him back but he did yeah yeah
yeah it's true it was a full-on
kidnapping we'll say it went through
[Music]
like this guy is a menace he's insane
like straight up and say yeah like he's
like anything in the name of science
let's go yeah see like that's the reason
why tony didn't want to go in the
elevator with him he had a feeling he
was like this guy's crazy
like the way he was moving he was like
come on tony i'm gonna just destroy the
world he's like i'd rather get laid
sorry nerd
hey
what if we brought the president over i
mean
come on let's just go get the president
let's get at the president
i love flashback killian he was so bad
it's so good
[Music]
but also speaking of iron man villains
let's go to justin hammer because um our
next candidate apparently already had
his day in court because he was in jail
because the last time we saw justin
hammer he was at the seagate
penitentiary serving time for all of his
terrible crimes in iron man 2. she built
all those drones he was like oh it
wasn't me and then i was like yes it was
you you're arrested
gotcha he created whiplash and who may
or may not still be alive i don't know
his trial will certainly be a big deal
if it has already happened so it's
possible that they've just kept him
locked up and hidden away in secrets and
not even all the prisoners at seagate
were aware of the millionaire inmate in
their midst though there were some who
knew exactly who he was but what charges
could be brought up against justin
hammer well let's start with aiding and
abetting the escape of an international
terrorist ivan vanko he totally did that
yeah he helped him get out of jail and
this guy he didn't really i won't say he
created whiplash like ivan venko he's
angry he's in russia he's bird i want my
board
tony's having a good time his dad's dead
he's like
well i build electric gables and whips
you know maybe build armor here build
some armor here i'm not gonna tell you
to do your job ivan okay but so he makes
himself he does the whole thing at
monaco very cool we're all into it and
justin helps this guy break out not cool
not cool not cool justin not cool and
very illegal i think they killed a
person in the process yeah of breaking
him out of prison like yeah he was
pretty messed up and of course another
crime is associating with the hydra
organization via senator stern because
uh that dude was mega hydra yeah he
could claim ignorance here i think
justin could claim ignorance on this one
but i think they're gonna slap this
they're gonna slap this charge on it
they're gonna slap it on this me waiting
to get slapped by legal i'm on the edge
of my seat they're gonna be like ah no
no you're in trouble yeah if i'm a good
lawyer
i'm gonna slap that child because they
set up at the beginning yeah if you're a
good lawyer you get this guy
i'm a really good lawyer because that
that that whole senate trial at the
beginning of uh or congressional hearing
at the beginning of iron man 2. it's
clear that stearns and hammer had a
whole plan they're like we're going to
get in there and then we're going to lay
this down on them and i'm gonna walk in
i'm gonna be dramatic
and then tony some crimes of his own
hacking shows off what's what's really
going on here okay but justin he's gonna
go down for this he's gonna get tied in
with this whole hydra breakdown oh for
sure like it's a it's all these villains
know each other yeah they're all they're
all friends just like take them all by
association lock them up lock them all
up i say we also have negligence with
weapons because whatever damage and
destruction ivan vanko cause could be
laid at hammer's feet because like it
was basically all of his technology um
being used here and with vanco dead the
government would want someone to take
the fall and that someone would be
justin hammer yeah because he can claim
like hey i didn't know what this guy was
doing he's in my lab he locked me out
you know you locked me out of the
software but yeah because i think i mean
i think whiplash was dead dead he's kind
of just like slumps over right like uh
like he's dead this is true they're
gonna blame hammer for all this he sort
of had an off-screen death in a way
because like it's implied that yes his
thing exploded right after the beats but
like he could have waited like for them
to leave and be like well
taking this off and i'm leaving and i'm
gone
also wear a helmet vanco wear a helmet
what's wrong with you yes one headshot
you're dead come on wear a helmet
and that's why we wear a helmet
something you kind of mentioned them t
and it could be possible like we saw
justin hammer in seagate prison in the
all hail the king one shot right and i
think he's kind of referenced in luke
cage because luke cage was also at
seagate it was like he didn't really
know anyways they could have hammer may
not have faced his trial yet he could
just be like locked up
and they're like we don't want to have
this trial yet it's going to expose too
much i think so much time has happened
that he must have been put on trial by
now unless they've got him hidden away
and they're they're telling the public
oh hammer's dead too but they just
haven't like locked up somewhere but i
think they would want this trial because
this is a guy that can nail this looks
good for them
boom easy conviction oh yeah easy
shutting kate i think that like he's
been well convicted a long time ago like
that but that that whole situation was
too much of a big deal for for there not
to be a fast conviction because there's
too many eyes on it yeah ruined the
stark expo it ruined the stark expo
absolutely ruined it my goodness they
had to redo it again but there's another
potentially dead villain that might not
actually be dead who if he does return
could actually be brought up on big
charges and that someone is darren cross
from ant-man one because while we saw
him viciously shrunk down into the
quantum realm in literally the most
gruesome fashion like one of the most
gruesome body horrors of the mcu good
god janet van dyne proved that it is
possible to survive and be brought back
so if they do ever bring daring cross
back what charges could he face well
right off the bat associating with
criminal and terrorist organizations for
the purposes of illegal arms sales hydra
he was working with a man called
mitchell carson um who used to be a
shield director of security and he was
actually hydra because shield was hydra
yeah and so after hydra fell he was like
hey let's work with darren cross because
it was a big little a little tiny army
for us which would actually be
terrible frightening
like actually it would have been like
ant-man really saved the day here
because like hydra having ant-man
technology would have absolutely been
terrible murder also big charge he
killed our boy frank arrest this man
lock him up one of the most gruesome
deaths in the mcu again terrible i feel
like that gun would be
if you made it into a gun form i feel
like ward be a lot less bloody it
basically was already a lot less bloody
yeah you just turned into a little like
oh those will be some good letters home
to parents like we sent your boy off to
war
he was on the battlefield something
happened i don't know but he's tiny too
now we can't find him the enemy put him
inside this
it's not this gun that is not the
solution to all warts well yes uh
there's also investor fraud because he's
been lying about the efficiency of his
tech to investors because he didn't 100
have the pimp particle formula down he
was like yeah i've got it don't worry i
just gotta gotta kill this old man first
he's definitely lying to some investors
for sure manslaughter of course because
uh two helicopter pilots got killed by
the lasers on the yellow jacket suit but
also there's also breaking and entering
cassie lang's house plus the false
imprisonment of cassie lange breaking
into a little girl's house that's a jail
forever in my opinion one million years
dungeon
no no bueno leave little girls bedrooms
alone i say yeah um yeah you better stay
in that quantum realm buddy because if
you come back to our l we're locking you
up you're going to the big house
so i was gonna be like
chris hanson's gonna be waiting for him
like excuse me we gotta talk about some
things he's just like in the same space
he's just like
and he comes back and he's like oh i
made it back thank god and then chris
hansen walks into the room like so you
like to be around little kids huh he's
like oh boy here we have a seat there
darren yeah yeah
he's like naked because he was in the
quantum realm but he's like
ah so you like to shrink down huh
also frank was my cousin
because while we're in the ant-man
universe we can also touch on sunny
bridge for a moment because while not
the biggest criminal mastermind he does
face a few charges including dealing in
illegal and stolen weapons and
technology that's his whole deal he's a
weapons dealer he's he's very proud of
it he's like i'll deal with a lot of
shady people and i make a lot of money
so give me that you know that they are
quantum energy j uh hope van dyne is
this your
impression i'm loving it yeah this is
good i don't know what i'm doing this is
good hey i'm a bad person there's that
there's also the false imprisonment of
the ex-con boys uh ti and and friends
injecting someone with drugs against
their will big crime big crime that was
the uh truth serum that wasn't a true
system but was totally a truth serum and
uh the reckless endangerment during the
car chase through san francisco a lot of
people were in danger you could lay all
that at their feet there was definitely
destruction someone might have been in a
minor accident causing some damage and
while some of it you could argue is
ant-man and the waff's fault i think
they're just going to pin it all on
sonny birch plus he's he's definitely
getting convicted because he was
captured he had the truth there man i'm
just leaking all this leaking all the
truth he was confessing everything we
also needed to add restaurant negligence
because he oh that's right that's right
attitude
sonny burch you're going to jail he's a
big time criminal but let's talk about a
different criminal now because another
criminal who has already been locked up
is adrian toomes aka vulture even though
you know he got arrested and thrown in
prison and got out by a weird multiverse
yeah technicality in morbius i don't
know spoilers for morbius if you haven't
seen
if you're if you're holding out on
morbius what are you doing bro if you
haven't seen morbius just just watch the
post-credits scene because that's the
only thing you need to watch but what
were the crimes of um adrian toombs
let's talk about theft let's talk theft
because uh that's his whole big deal his
big spiel in homecoming he loves
stealing alien tech especially from
government agencies like the department
of damage control he was all about
stealing and selling black market
weapons which is weapons trafficking
which is a second crime because he was
overseeing the production of in the
sales of weapons using highly illegal
technology very dangerous technology
that was very reactive to like different
types of radiation like x-ray or
radiation like you know the washington
monument also the destruction of
government property because the
washington monument sort of on him in a
way yeah yeah cause like if he never
stole it like could they pin that on him
i don't know well but also any any
facility he's breaking into right any
trucks that he's damaging as part of his
theft that's all government property
boom easy lock it up yes true it also
just the nature of uh his
his being he violated protected air
space uh just by flying around but also
being on that plane and trying to steal
all that technology from tony stark yeah
he tried to hijack that plane big big
violation and uh assaulting a minor we
got to talk about this because uh peter
was a teenager throughout that entire
ordeal so uh peter would have been
underage during their fight but does the
memory spell wipe clear that charge from
his record oh that's a good point yeah
if they bring him up on we know he was
in jail and he was in jail right for
whatever he probably wasn't in jail for
assaulting spider-man because they don't
know who spider-man is at this point but
eventually they would figure it out in
far from home at the end of far from
they figured out so now they know he's a
teenager he's under 18 at the time of
these crimes you could go back and throw
that on there maybe but then the memory
spell would happen and they'd be like oh
never mind we don't know what this
charge is for we'll wipe that one off i
i think that assaulting a minor might be
thrown out because they don't know that
spider-man's a minor right but even if
they know let's say they know
spider-man's a minor i think you could
say like well spider-man put himself in
that situation it's not like he went to
spider-man's house it was like put your
fists up sucka it's time for a fight
like spider-man got involved in all this
yeah okay that's fine we'll let him walk
on that we'll let him walk on that
charge okay but he's still going to jail
for a long time if uh if it wasn't for
morbius anyway um thanks morbius thanks
dr michael morbius but now here's an
interesting one that could be considered
um wanda maximoff because using the
parameters that we've established today
do we think that wanda could be brought
up on charges for the actions in west
view okay empty let's think about this
all right she is sokovian she doesn't
have an american citizenship and we
think we think that the sokovia courts
kind of wipe the slate clean for
everybody right they were like yeah yeah
we're we're gonna have these and if you
were a superhero and you did something
and you're cool you're cool you're cool
because in this scenario we've set up
right the department of justice they
can't go after aliens they can't go
after like interdimensional beings they
kind of stay away from like they're
going after like u.s citizens who are
committing these crimes she's not one
but she commits this crime on u.s soil
the west view this would be all the west
view stuff right this happens after the
sokovia accord so what could they charge
her with they could charge her with i
guess like false imprisonment right
because she imprisoned that right true
that's like hundreds of people with
false imprisonments that's that's a huge
crime destruction of property some
things get destroyed i would say yeah i
would say so as well i mean like you
know mind control i feel like there's
like a healing is there a crime for mind
control is my control a crime
i don't that's not well is that on the
books i guess like sort of like she
forced her will on somebody a bunch of
people so like that someone like forcing
yourself on someone else i think that's
a crime like when it's something
right most definitely that's unfair yes
no one's arguably not empty and there's
also children involved i would say just
destruction of property and then did
anyone die in in west view did any like
soldiers or police officers die they get
changed but they don't necessarily like
ever die no one got killed killed right
besides vision who dies all the time i
don't yet i don't think anyone died in
west view but like maybe like but we
don't know if those kids any of those
kids
were hurt because like some kids might
have allergies or allergies like
sicknesses and like and they were like
who knows
i have to eat chocolate today cause
she's like uh she's not working hard on
like the outer ones right they're mostly
just like sleeping or standing still but
one of them she's like yeah kids like
chocolate eat some chocolate in the
kitchen
so yeah we'll
we'll pin uh a salt we'll pin assault
definitely on her but here's the thing
if sokovia is like not gonna if she like
she leaves right they kind of let her
leave but who's gonna stop her how are
you gonna arrest the scarlet witch you
can't arrest her you can't put her in
jail you'd have to involve the
sorcerer's supreme but she's stronger
than the of so you're never going to get
her arrested and you're never going to
get her in a courtroom it's not safe for
anybody in there i think they just let
her go that's why they let her they were
like we're not even going to try i think
that they might take a page out of the
clandestines book and just like exile
her
which is something that wanda wanted
anyway
to leave the universe i like it anyway
so they'd probably be like doctor
strange kick her out because like she
give her what she wants like put her put
her out of here i like this idea that
she leaves and the the department of
justice is like well
you can't ever come back how about that
boom
problem solved next case don't come back
period we're not going to come after you
but please don't ever come back we're
begging you please we have to use
westview as the point for like the
charges that one it could be brought up
on because like all the things that she
did in multiverse of madness weren't
necessarily on u.s soil a lot of them
but also no one really knew what she did
like a lot of all of her actions in
multiverse of madness were unknown to
the eyes of the general public like
there was it's mainly a commerce like
mystical realm
thing that happened and all the people
that died were mainly magic people so
like as far as
people in new york know wanda is just
chilling like they don't really know
where she's at she's never gonna do
anything wrong
unless someone unless someone snitches
on her about being in charge of
gargantos they could blame all the
garganto stuff on her unless unless
steven's a little [ __ ] he's got a
snitch on her
you know honestly i don't think that
steven said anything because like we saw
that the illuminati erected a statue for
steve and it's like yo people need
heroes people need some of them to
believe in and because that wanna
destroyed the darkhold at the end of the
movie i think steven is going to do the
same thing and like erect a statue for
wanda and be like oh okay he saved
everyone oh and she's a hero and she
died being a hero and so i think that
that's what they were setting up there
so i think
people don't really know you're off the
hook wanda you're off the hook wanda
you're off the hook for everything after
west vietnam totally fine you're fine
please don't hurt me but who do we think
is the biggest criminal in the mcu in
the eyes of the u.s government i mean i
think it's got to be our boy aldrich
killian right he is a big time criminal
capital c criminal this is huge like he
kidnapped the president yeah
like even the stuff even the stuff you
could get like wilson fisk on if you
even take just daredevils wilson fisk
and we know he gets arrested and goes to
jail his crimes are nothing a little
murder here and there please kidnap the
president and then talk to me all right
fun fun yeah there's no higher quality
create a domestic terrorist and then
talk to me okay like come on get out of
here
get out of here all just killian is the
number one get out of here bad guy it's
got to be killian i would say killian
who would give him run for his money
maybe uh
oh loki would but like loki yeah oh
that's a good point i think yeah i think
loki would give him a run for his money
even though only 74 people died that's
got to be a lie total lie total lie stop
lying to us government stop
you lying [ __ ] stop
yeah i think well yeah you would put
loki as like a bigger criminal but
they're never you could never even put
loki on trial like unless you had the
technology to keep them locked up and
like wrapped up but like loki's gonna
live for five thousand years what jail
are you gonna put them in like it
doesn't even make sense it's true you
can't stop true like they're just gonna
send them to asgard anyways the second
you turn your back he's gonna
shape-shift into the guard and you're
like how did you get in the cell get out
of there jerry and then he's free
seriously
like loki could escape the raft if you
wanted to oh yeah this dude is just like
[Laughter]
but yeah i i would definitely agree
argus killian is probably the biggest
fan of all if you're still alive yeah if
you are out there killian you better
keep running we need to regrow that
buddy and put him on trial but be sure
to head on over to rockstarsmerch.com to
check out all of our awesome merch
options because right now we have our
newest latest accession shirt worthy of
love inspired by for love and thunder
that shirt is limited edition and won't
be available for much longer so make
sure you grab it while you can and
support the channel and all the great
work that we do by heading on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com
today and also did you know that new
rockstars has a live show that happens
every weekday right here on our youtube
channel that's right everybody the break
room goes live every weekday at 3 p.m
pacific and it's broadcast from our
actual break room at new rockstars hq we
talk about all the biggest nerd news
from the day interact with the chat and
even manage to have a little mandatory
fun every now and then so check out the
break room on our channel and be sure to
join us live if you can because we'd
love to have you it's really fun but yes
now it is time for our bite size
questions brandon are you ready oh baby
i love a little bite science question
um
eat that bite size
munchkin no brandon are there kang
variants in the andrew or toby
spiderverse and this is from oh march 37
on discord i mean i think you got to say
most definitely right mt you know he who
remains laid out in loki that there were
multiple universes stacked on top of
each other and with those other
universes come other kangs and while he
doesn't in that episode outright say
that every universe has a king i would
reason he's like a pretty standard
figure right like maybe even a nexus
being like kang is he's got to be there
right he he's a
pin he's a focal point of every universe
now since we know that both toby mcguire
and andrew garfield universes are
connected to the mcu and the death of he
who remains allowed them to be pulled
into the mcu it means that there's a
high probability that their universe is
also contained tangs right their
universes are
very similar to the mcu in so much that
it's earth and it's got new york city
and i got spider boys right there it's
not like one of them came from that like
liquid paint universe we saw in
multiverse of madness like the kang from
that universe might be very strange or
maybe not exist at all
[Laughter]
not very useful now here's one thing i
was thinking empty let's say that like
because those universes have like marvel
heroes they also have a kang
could their kangs already be dead like
could they have been killed by another
kang or something like that and they're
just like left like what if the reason
like their universes don't have like
avengers and all these other heroes is
because a ken got to their universe and
like pruned it in like a weird way where
he like killed their kang and that like
stopped anything else from happening so
there's a spider boy but there's nothing
else
like what if that's what happened
in their universes i think that there
are definitely multiple kings in
different um like universes and i think
that the kang he remains killed all of
those kings in the past and like they
all had their own versions of tvas and i
think that like the the raymond universe
has a kang andrew garfield has a king
the x-men universe has a kang and i
think that like the x-men universe could
potentially be where loki went to at the
end of loki where where sylvie sent him
to
a whole new tva you know a statue of
kang that's already erected i think that
that that tva could have had a kang that
was killed and whoever is uh like the in
the seat of he who remains in that
universe in that multiverse rather
is sort of like passing off kang as like
oh yeah he's he's your god but like you
know he's dead and like i'm the real god
okay like that could be uh rent slayer
that could be um
whoever's in charge ah i like that idea
i like the idea that there's multiple
kangs who act like he who remains and
they all thought that they were the ones
that were like i'm gonna shield myself
from all the other kangs when in
actuality there is a bunch of kangs
doing that keeping their little
universes safe oh i love this mt i love
it so many kings so many kangs but
here's another question for you brandon
august 13th is international
left-handers day so are there any marvel
or dc characters identified as
left-handed and this is from millennial
on discord thank you
hopefully your
your millennium gets a little bit more
exciting
this is a real matt planium for sure so
it seems like about 10 of the population
considers themselves left-handed all
right and so i was looking into this and
like they don't really say
which heroes and villains are like
left-handed like a lot of people are
like oh captain america uses his left
arm as his shield arm and some people
argue that this means he's left-handed
because he'll throw with that arm
sometimes i don't know it's very
confusing and a lot of times i saw
drawings where it was on both sides and
i think that's like a lot of how it is
for a lot of these heroes because
they're so
smart and strong and ambidextrous or
whatever they can just use whatever hand
they want to use it doesn't matter well
like the same thing for bucky people are
like oh because his left arm is his
metal arm maybe he's left-handed now and
like i i don't know i don't think so
why didn't you use the metal arm
well i don't always think of it
immediately i'm
right-handed it's hard to say it's
really hard to say but there is an
obscure marvel villain named left hand
who comes from the new warriors comics
of the early 1990s don't we just love
the new warriors and he's
he's called left hand because he shoots
destructive energy from his left hand
but honestly i don't know if he writes
with that hand or not he has to use that
hand for his power so they call him left
hand i don't know if he's like actually
left-handed or he's like well i have to
shoot it out of here now i think i think
we can count hellboy as left-handed okay
though he's not marvel or dc he's
darkhorse so this goes outside of your
question right but because his big you
know stone hand is his right hand he's
definitely using his left hand to like
do stuff he's not riding with the stone
hand he's not cooking with it he's not
you know petting a dog he's using his
left hand to do a lot of stuff so i will
say boom hell boy is left-handed he's
got to be left-handed then of course
there's the famous green lantern villain
sinestro who is often shown wearing his
ring on his left hand and this is sort
of like married because he's married
this is sort of like an easter egg kind
of thing that the artists like to do a
lot because apparently like
so
sinestra is the word from which sinestro
is derived it's a latin word and it
means left in ancient land but thanks to
folklore over time like left-handedness
became associated with evil which is
really messed up sorry to all my
left-handed people out there my mother's
left-handed she's not evil i promise but
because of all this like association
with like the left hand and like
evilness and the devil the word sinister
came about from sinestra and sinestro is
very similar similar to sinister so a
lot of the artists have started putting
the left
or the power ring on sinestro's left
hand to kind of signify like oh he's
that evil that's how sinister he is he
even puts his ring right in his hand
he's crazy he's left-handed man that's
crazy
we should have never trusted him but as
soon as he put that green lantern right
on his left we should have never
betrayed us also this is just another
great way to point out how it's insane
that humanity has made it this far when
we were a bunch of crazy people
wandering around being like that man's
left-handed he must be evil kill him
immediately like what is wrong with
people which is a witch left-handed
probably a witch now here's here's a
good one empty so in the mcu ulysses
clow's weaponized arm is his left arm
and it you know it looks like a hand and
then it opens up and it's got a gun and
but in the comics it's his right arm
that is the weapon and in the comics
it's not like his weapon arm is like a
fake hand that opens up it's like this
crazy
gun thing like contraption yeah yeah so
because in the comics that's his right
arm he has to be using his left hand in
the comics so our boy claw is definitely
left-handed ulysses claw left-handed
write it down he's your winner confirmed
confirmed here's another fun little uh
tidbit scarlett johansson and jeremy
renner the actors are both left-handed
you can see pictures of them signing
autographs with their left hand but it
seems like for the most part their
characters are ambidextrous so like okay
you can't say black widow and hawkeye
are left-handed because they're peak
humans they can use any hand they want
they're incredible at everything you
can't i think they they they train you
in uh both
ambidextrousness in the red room yeah
yeah it's one of those things that they
it's the only good thing they do in the
red room the only good thing
the only good oh my gosh really thank
god that guy's dead bring him up on
charge that's the worst but here's what
matters the most folks for international
left handers day our beloved stan lee he
was left-handed
blessed is true not an evil man either
not an evil man he's a good guy not evil
r.i.p stanley we miss you bless you and
your left hand
mourinho told you yes you got to
remember spider-man was created with the
left hand never forget it never forget
it that's why he's evil we gotta get
this spider menace that's why he's a
menace
if jane if jane and jonah jameson could
ever prove that spider-man was
left-handed he would he would print that
on the front page why don't you back it
up with a source my sources that i made
it the [ __ ] up yeah like open and shut
case i did see spider-man left-handed i
did see someone point out that like i
think in the tom holland uses his left
hand to talk on the phone so people were
saying like oh spider-man's left-handed
but again he's like he's too smart he
can use whatever hand he wants it it
doesn't affect him i use my left hand
attack on the phone sometimes yeah i do
too i'm right-handed i don't know people
are crazy that's weird these these
left-handed maniacs they want to claim
anyone that can
they gotta play
but here's our box of scraps time
brandon
okay with the box
subscribes i'm opening a fake box
i'm opening the box i took something out
of it it's a it's a scrap oh i'm eating
it
don't each now you're supposed to build
with the boxes
it's too late i need any surgery of my
chest
i've eaten fat that's wrapped up in my
heart that's how you become iron man you
eat the scraps
exactly i'm trying to become iron man
all right brandon our box of scraps
question of today is if you had to be a
villain in the mcu
which villain would you want to be this
is a dark dark question i don't want to
be a bad i want to be a bad guy but i
want to be a bad bad guy you know you
don't want to be like the worst of the
worst i i would be the tinkerer the
tanker is chill okay
that's good yeah yeah i like that yeah
yeah you can blame your crimes on other
people yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he was
just like i'm just messing with alien
stuff i didn't tell him to use it as a
gun i was just trying to make stuff
right i was just trying to make i'm just
making guns people just pick the guns up
i don't know
i think
i mean this is dark to say
i think i'd want to be justin hammer
he's got a pretty yo he's cool that's a
cool dude i think if you could i would
just i would keep my ego in check i
would be like it's okay to be the number
two manual manufacturer of weapons in
the world that's fine i don't i don't
need to be number one i got this private
plane i got self-tanning lotion i'm
gonna be okay i'm gonna be okay i got
sweet dance moves yeah i think i would
be justin hammer you know every now and
then i get a little crazy but uh yeah
i'll be justin hammer you'd be the
tanker like you're still amazing
like you're you're still living good
still living good yeah we could we could
work on something man that's what dick
or justin hammer teemo let's work
together yo yeah match made in heaven
but that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank brandon for
joining me on this wonderful episode
please follow him at grindenberric on
twitter he's an amazing man follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but follow
new rockstars wherever we are on the
internet and especially on youtube when
you do on youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you want to continue the
conversation join our new rockstars
discord server if you're over 18 and
interested click the link for the new
rockstars discord server in the
description box below and join the
conversation because we are having so
much fun on our discord so come on over
we love you and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye bye
[Music]
you